Well,
how are you, Héctor Mejía greets you with his
brief informative for today, Wednesday
, September 29,
this morning, the superintendent of the cis
is already speaking with the subcommittee of the
House of Representatives about the
impact of the pandemic on
schools, doctor jesús talk included topics such
as  the change in learning and
teaching due to the cobat they will try to
execute a plan to return to
normality tomorrow the board of directors the
university education system will vote
on whether to implement the
mandatory code vaccine if this happens this
will require university employees
they are fully
vaccinated by December 1st or they
will lose their jobs however there are
exceptions related to health or
religion until September 20 it was
reported that around one in
five employees has not been vaccinated and an
Audi travels to its testing site  and
vaccination
this center will reopen in the
parking lot in front of this month on
stage  the hours of operation
and will remain the same as always from Sunday to
Thursday from 5:30 p.m. to
10:30 p.m. now we turn to
the weather forecast we will have
temperatures reaching just 82
degrees for the maximum we will see some
breezes in the valley that will remain
until Friday however for the
weekend we return to the nineties to
enjoy these last days of heat
have a nice newspaper selector mejía
this was your brief informative on
kirchner in spanish
[Music]